[Music]
supermarket shelves are stocked with a
vast selection of tasty ready-made salad
dressings and marinades
dressing adds instant pizzazz to salad
whereas marinade flavors and tenderizes
raw food by slow penetration over a few
hours prior to cooking
salad dressings can be cream or
mayonnaise-based or oil and
vinegar-based
this particular line of dressings and
marinades is made entirely of certified
organic ingredients it's also
gluten-free and sugar-free for those
with celiac disease or diabetes
while the salad dressings base stays
much the same
the seasoning ingredients vary to create
different flavors such as the one we're
about to see being made
sun-dried tomato and garlic vinaigrette
on the production floor they start by
heating water then adding tomato paste
next they add dried basil
they pour all ingredients directly into
the vortex created by the mixing blade
to ensure thorough blending
next they add sun-dried tomatoes
minced garlic
and salt after 15 more minutes of mixing
they add soybean oil and extra virgin
olive oil both expeller pressed meaning
extracted from the source naturally
using a mechanical press and not the
conventional chemical process
the last ingredient is gluten-free red
wine vinegar whereas the oils provide
both taste and texture this vinegar
produces a full-bodied flavor
cooking another 20 minutes or so on high
heat stabilizes the product giving
unopened dressing a shelf life of up to
a year
on the bottling line a machine called
the inverter flips the empty glass
bottles upside down
then from underneath an air nozzle
shoots in a blast of filtered air this
loosens any dust or dirt particles
inside the bottle enabling a vacuum to
then suction the mount
another inverter flips the bottles right
side up again as they enter the filling
machine
exiting the filler the bottles pass
through a machine which dispenses
plastic caps then with a row of spinning
discs twist them on
finally a tamper-proof seal and labels
the marinade production process is much
the same but with different ingredients
of course
this batch is sesame teriyaki flavor of
which a key component is gluten-free
tamari a japanese soy sauce made without
wheat again the process begins by
heating water in a cook kettle they pump
in tamari
pour in salt
then powdered ginger
next minced garlic and sesame seeds
then agave nectar a natural sweetener
that's low glycemic
they add pureed ginger
then expeller press soybean oil mixed
with xanthan gum a natural thickener
about 20 minutes cooking on high heat
and this sesame teriyaki marinade is
ready for bottling
like before the glass bottles undergo a
vacuum cleaning and route to the filler
there piston suck up the marinade like a
syringe
then inject it into the bottles
the filled bottles go through the capper
then travel on a conveyor belt to the
next machine which slips a plastic
neckband over each cap
[Music]
a shot of hot steam shrinks the neckband
tightly around the cap creating a tamper
seal
finally the labeling machine applies
glue to the back of a paper label then
wraps it around the passing bottle
besides flavoring and tenderizing raw
food before cooking
you can also pour marinade over meat
fish or vegetables while cooking
a surefire way to let the gourmet out of
the bottle
you